2500 c'est le nombre de visiteurs qui
étaient attendus pendant le week-end du
festival bd à buc des passionnés venus
rencontrer leurs auteurs favoris et
profiter des séances de dédicaces là
j'attends pour avoir des gaz de monsieur
olivier pâques
voilà sur le voyage de l'oit verser de
louis xiii et fait partie de mes
distributeurs préfet je parle avec
olivier martin qui est en train de faire
un efficace sur l'album s'appelle j'ai
tué mara et que j'ai adoré et donc du
coup on est train de discuter un petit
peu de comment il avait conçu l'album
etc puis j'attends qu'ils finissent le
dessin et c'est ça qui est plutôt
intéressant dans un salon de bande
dessinée c'est vraiment rencontrer des
auteurs qui nous ont fait rêver en
lisant des albums et parmi les auteurs
présents sur place et thierry capezzone
et le dessinateur de p2i car si le p tit
rafle le dernier album le cochon volant
qu'on a fait aux éditions aux éditions
correct et c'est magique c'est une bd ou
au petit la construire un avion et c'est
un avion tu sais qu'on avait dans le
temps en avion à cannes élastique dedans
je suis venu dédicacer des albums de
pepsi pezi c'est un personnage danois de
1951 qui va fêter ses soixante dix ans
allait prochaine et donc je fais ça moi
j'ai repris la série depuis 2011
au total 25 auteurs étaient présents
lors de l'événement